[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute machen wir mit
hackfleisch spitzen die könnt ihr sowohl
warm als auch kalt genießen also auch
für ein büfett super geeignet für den
teig und da geht jetzt auch wirklich
super schnell und einfach benötigen wir
550 gramm mehl 200 milliliter wasser 50
gramm neutrales öl ein halbe packung
trockenhefe einen halben teelöffel salz
und ein ei zuerst geben wir die
trockenhefe mit zu mehl und verrühren
das gründlich miteinander und danach
kommen auch schon die restlichen zutaten
mit den zug
das wasser das öl das weiß und das ei
und dann wird das ganze gründlich
miteinander verkettet
[Musik]
nach circa fünf minuten habt ihr dann
schon einen geschmeidigen teig gespielte
dann aber immer noch mal gerne ein paar
minuten auf der arbeitsfläche weiter und
dann habt ihr auch schon euren teig
fertig nimmt euch auch gerne ein
bisschen öl zu hilfe wenn das ganze
ankleben sollte ihr solltet einen
schönen festen zeit heraus bekommen dann
rolle ich das ganze zu einer schönen
kugel für netze das noch mal mit etwas
öl und lasse es 30 minuten lang an einem
warmen ort gehen
zwischen mache ich schon mal die füllung
fertig dafür benötigen wir 500 gramm
rinder hackfleisch hier habe ich schon
eine große zwiebel fein gehackt und gebe
sie mit hackfleisch das vermisse ich
dann nur ganz grob miteinander denn
jetzt kommen noch die restlichen zutaten
mit den vorher habe ich eine handvoll
gewürzen sollte meinen infobox das
schreibe ich euch genau hin was ihr
dafür braucht ein ei für die bindung
ganz wichtig ist hier auch das mehl das
gebe ich an meinen auch noch mit andrew
obwohl wird das ei für die bindung haben
können wir auch dass mir jedoch nicht
verzichten also nicht auf jeden fall
beides so schnell ist die füllung fertig
und weiter geht's mit unseren tiefe teig
auf der bemehlten arbeitsfläche weil ich
den teig jetzt ganz dünn aus
an dieser stelle kann ich noch oft sagen
also dss nicht gedacht für diese
typischen teigtaschen jemand an einem
ofen zubereitet der ist er gedacht für
diese mini pizzen mit traten nämlich
anschließend an und jetzt nehme ich mir
eine schüssel zur hand nimmt einfach die
größe die euch am besten gefällt und
dann einfach treibe heraus stechen um
den teig jetzt vor dem austrocknen zu
schützen gibt sie bitte unter
frischhaltefolie und dann geht es weiter
mit dem befüllen
ich ziehe immer ca 1 esslöffel
hackfleisch füllung pro tag
den äußeren rand lasse ich frei und
drückte ihn dann in die mitte hin
zusammen
und dann könnt ihr dann noch ein
bisschen rein drücken damit ihr dann
dieses muster erhaltet außerdem fällt
das ganze dann viel besser und dann
geht's weiter am herd ein sonnenblumenöl
habe ich auf mittlerer stufe erhitzt und
gäbe dann mit der oberfläche zuerst die
mini pizzen in die pfanne lastet auf
drei minuten lang braten und resi dann
um nach weiteren zwei minuten sind die
mini pizzen dann auch schon fertig
schaut aber trotzdem immer wieder unten
drunter diese aussehen und dann könnt
ihr auch schon servieren wir euch auch
von innen das gute ist die sind außen
werks luftig und ihnen wieder etwas
weicher und dann wünsche ich euch ganz
viel spaß beim nachmachen wenn euch das
video gefallen hat lassen wir doch gerne
einen daumen nach oben und ich sag bis
zum nächsten mal auf dieses kitchen